solve for x and y we have the system of
equations right here we have 2x minus y
is equal to 14 and negative 6x plus 3y
is equal to negative 42. so we could try
to solve this by elimination and maybe
we want to let's see if we can eliminate
let's see if we can eliminate our y
variables first we have a 3y here and we
have a negative y up here and we can
they won't eliminate if you just add
negative y plus 3y that won't eliminate
but if we could turn this negative y
into a negative 3y then it would cancel
out with a 3y and the best way to turn a
negative y into a negative 3y is to
multiply this entire top equation by 3.
so let's do that let's multiply let me
get some space over to the left let's
multiply this entire top equation
by 3. so i'm going to multiply it by 3.
so i multiply 2x by 3 i get 6x i
multiply negative y by 3 i get negative
3y
and then i multiply fourteen by three
mult
three times fourteen is forty two right
three times ten is thirty plus twelve
it's forty two
and then we can add both of these
equations and something interesting
should already maybe be showing up on
your radar
let's add both of these equations let's
add the left hand side negative 6x plus
6x well those cancel out we get 0. then
we have 3y minus 3y those cancel out we
get another zero and then finally you
get negative 42 plus 42 well that's zero
so we end up with just zero is equal to
zero which is clearly true but it's not
putting any constraints on the x or y
and that's because whenever you have a
situation like this where you just get
something that's obviously true zero
equals zero or one equals one or five
equals five what we're dealing in a
situation is where both of our
constraints both of our equations are
actually the same equation so this right
here is a dependent system
it is a dependent
it is a dependent system and you see it
right over here if you take that first
equation you multiply it by 3 you got 6x
minus 3y is equal to 42. if we then
multiply it by negative 1 if we then
multiplied it by negative 1 you would
get this you would get the exact same
equation as the second equation you
would get negative 6x
plus 3y is equal to negative 42. or
another way to think about it if you
want to go from the first equation to
the second equation you just multiply
both sides of the equation times
times negative 3. so both of these
constraints are actually the same
constraints they're just kind of a
scaled up multiple of each other so if
you were to graph them and i might as
well graph them for you right here this
first equation right here let me do it
over here it's 2x
minus y is equal to 14. i could subtract
2x from both sides and you would get let
me just subtract it subtract 2x subtract
2x
on the left hand side you're left with
just negative y
on the right hand side you have negative
2x
plus 14 multiply both sides by negative
1 and you get y is equal to 2x
minus 14. so this first equation over
here if i were to draw my axes
so that is my y-axis
and then that is my x-axis
this graph right over here its
y-intercept is negative 14. so this is 0
negative 14 0
negative 14 and has a slope of 2. so
it's going to look something like this
it's going to look something like that
and then the second equation if you were
to graph it because this is a dependent
system it's the exact same line if you
were to put this in slope intercept form
and graph it you would get the exact
same thing you would it would go right
on top of it so there's actually an
infinite number of solutions these two
lines are the same line so they
intersect everywhere on each of the
respective lines they're the same line
and that's where and when you get
something like this zero equals zero or
one equals one that's the telltale sign
that you're dealing with a dependent
system if you got something like zero
equals one then you would have no
solution so this would right here would
be an inconsistent
inconsistence
this would be an inconsistent system
and this would be the situation so let
me make it very clear this is a
situation we're dealing with the same
same lines the lines are the same lines
this is a situation where you have
parallel lines
parallel
and so they never intersect and then
obviously you have the
the the easiest situation i think this
is one most of us familiar with where
you have something like x is equal to
one or y is equal to two or anything
like this doesn't have to be one or two
and then this is clearly a situation
where you have an independent system
where you have two different lines that
intersect in exactly one place anyway
this there's an infinite number of
solutions any x and y that satisfy the
first equation will also satisfy the
second equation because there's
fundamentally the same constraint